So the other reaction I want to show you is the anti-Marcovnikov hydrohallogenation.
So remember when we were looking at addition reactions, we were looking at hydrohallogenation
and we were understanding that that was a regio-specific reaction.
Regio-specific meaning that the halogen would always go to the more substituted of the
two carbons participating in the pi bond because of the fact that it would only go by the
more stable carbocation intermediate.
Remember this pi bond would get the proton, leave the secondary carbocation and then
that's where the bromide would go and we'd get the Marcovnikov product in a regio-specific
manner.
But then we didn't look at the mechanism but we also noted the fact that in the presence
of peroxides this would shift to anti-Marcovnikov regio-specificity.
In other words we would get the halogen on the less substituted of the two carbons participating
in the pi bond.
And we didn't look at why, well here's why, it's a free radical reaction and so the peroxides
obviously play a very key role in this.
So let's take a look.
The initiation step is going to be provided by the peroxides and so remember when we talked
about oxygen, oxygen, covalent bonds as ones that are able to undergo homolytic bond
cleavage.
That's the initiation step.
So we have this oxygen oxygen covalent bond undergoing homolysis and then we get two
hydroxyl radicals.
So it's those hydroxyl radicals that are going to propagate the formation above other
radicals.
So let's say that a hydroxyl radical finds one of these molecules of HBR.
Well what's going to happen is this radical and then one electron from this covalent bond
are going to form a new one and now we've got a water molecule and then that's going
to propagate the existence of a bromine radical.
Then from there this is the key step because this is where the regio specificity is involved.
The bromine radical is going to interact with this pi bond that is necessary for the
addition reaction and what's going to happen is it's going to form a new carbon bromine
bond but it is going to do it in regio specific manner because of the stability of the alkyo
radical that it will generate.
So in other words one of these pi electrons is going to go to form a covalent bond with
this bromine radical and it is only going to happen here because if it does so then the
other pi electron will go to this carbon, the secondary carbon leaving the more stable
of the two possible alkyo radical intermediates.
If the bromine radical interacted at this position and this pi electron went to form the
new carbon bromine bond there then that would mean that the other pi electron would be
left on the primary carbon and we then have a primary alkyo radical intermediate and
that is the less stable of the two so it will not produce that.
So in a regio specific manner the bromine will add to the less substituted of the two
carbons participating in the pi bond.
That leaves an alkyo radical intermediate which will then go ahead and undergo another
step with HBR and it will just extract a proton there leaving another bromine radical
there.
Recall once again that these are all single headed electron pushing arrows denoting
the movement of a singular electron and so we have gotten to our product here.
This is our anti-marcovnicoff hydro halogenation product regio specific to be the less substituted
alkyo bromide of the two possibilities and we have managed to do it all with propagation
steps there could be termination steps choose anything.
This radical bromine radical hydroxyl radical anything if two radical species meet they'll
terminate but none of them were needed in the mechanism generating the products so we didn't
draw them.
So once again hydroxyl radical initiates propagates the existence of the bromine radical and
then the bromine radical goes ahead and adds in regio specific manner specifically in an
anti-marcovnicoff manner so that it generates the more stable of the possible alkyo radical
intermediates.
So that will shed some light on the mystery we understood the mechanism before for the
Marcovnicoff hydro halogenation and now we know the mechanism for the anti-marcovnicoff
variety as well.
Thanks for watching guys subscribe to my channel for more tutorials and as always feel
free to email me questions professor Dave explains at gmail.com